buenas tardes mañana muy amable
publicitación esto se ha complicado
porque parecería hacer que es el
comienzo de una nueva intifada
infortunadamente la coincidencia del
ramadán con la fiesta que ocurre cada 33
años y que las tres religiones se
encuentran y lo que ocurrió la semana
anterior el viernes pasado que las
fuerzas israelíes se vieron obligadas a
entrar al
templo del monte o al templo a la
explanada o como lo llaman los
musulmanes la mezquita la explanada y
exacerbó los ánimos y trajo la situación
a este nivel de que en los últimos ocho
días hubo siete días de confrontación y
parece que esto va a seguir prolongando
y la medida de apretar a los
trabajadores genera más tensiones
y precisamente esos ataques contra la
mezquita de la explanada fueron los que
desencadenaron la guerra de 11 días del
año pasado que tan cerca podríamos estar
de una guerra como la de ese entonces
infortunadamente maría clara muy cerca
porque es que las tensiones como se
viven allá y en especial ahí cerquita en
la ciudad oriental
es muy es un ambiente muy pesado y
cuando ocurre una actividad de estas
inmediatamente cierran las carreteras
hacia
nazaret o hacia hebrón y se comienzan
esos enfrentamientos callejeros y vienen
los choques y los jóvenes que sienten
que su futuro no es muy claro y que les
han metido tanta cosa en la cabeza se
extienden y con la presencia de los
colonos en la cisjordania peor todavía
porque la situación se complica más y
como hay unas personas que guardan la
línea del señor beteta en yahoo entonces
se multiplican esos odios y las
tensiones parecería tender a que podría
repetirse lo del año pasado y como le
decía al principio para que se
desarrolle una nueva intifada que es
prácticamente una guerra abierta y
permanente y la franja de casa tiene un
bloqueo por parte de israel y de egipto
desde hace más de 15 años desde que
hamás tomó el poder en ese contexto
tanto afecta el cierre de la frontera
afecta para entrar a israel mano a
egipto porque en egipto lo que hicieron
fue de destruir una parte de la ciudad
de rafáh o rafa y dejar un espacio
pondrás en los túneles pero es que esa
historia de los túneles es eterna maría
clara cuando uno está ya eso es a diario
que están descubriendo los y sale uno y
aparece otro porque hay unas mafias
alrededor y en la parte ya donde pasan
de gaza a israel o sea en oriente el
problema es el temor de la seguridad y
como han ocurrido tantas situaciones
entonces los soldados israelíes se ven
presionados y de vez en cuando aparecen
la yihad islámica o el vino a más
lanzando cohetes y en este momento e
irán desafortunadamente por medio de su
parque hezbollah y las guerrillas que
están al sur del líbano y el siria está
apoyando e instigando a que se forme un
conflicto mayor y de paso israel no
perdona objetivo que detecta en síria
entonces las tensiones son permanentes y
se podría repetir una intifada con
resultados impredecibles maria clara
gracias por estar con nosotros en france